hello everyone and welcome to the
elaborate precision medicine virtual
event my name is Gwen Ann Wong and I'm a
senior research investigator here at
University of Pennsylvania and I will be
presenting today on bringing precision
medicine to veterinary oncology
he is feel free to submit questions
during my presentation and I will follow
up with you via email
first I like to thank Chris tile science
to invite me here today to share my work
and lab roots for coordinating share
with you our effort at Penn to bring
precision medicine to veterinary
oncology
so here's my disclosure
on the menu today at the beginning I
will show you the concept of precision
medicine and how it is changing the
landscape of a human oncology of
although I don't think that's a you know
a big issue for this audience then I
will share with you our study in Cana
hemangioma applying the concept of a
precision medicine and the NGS basic
Diagnostics to identify clinically
actionable markers lastly I talk about
our efforts to build a broad clinic
answer panel designed to use in many
types of the common canine cancers so I
like to start today's talk with the
story of a seven year old German
Shepherd dog Jakob Jakob was the
happiest dog in the world one day he
just he started to show lethargy and the
witness before he completely collapsed a
week after ultrasound revealed hemo
abdomen and a large splenic mass which
was later diagnosed as Himeno sarcoma
Jakob underwent splenectomy right away
to remove primary tumor followed by
chemotherapy to slow metastatic spread
however despite that the metastatic
disease red play appears and he died
three months after initial diagnosis
is one of the sad stories of a millions
of dogs diagnosed with commando sarcoma
and erratically succumb to the disease
and a very little can we do
at this point to help them
so being a hardcore saga lovers who have
witnessed the rise of precision medicine
and how it revolutionizes cancer care in
human patients as shown here by
delivering the most effective treatment
based on deep patient genotyping and
phenotyping so I me and my team at UPenn
have the same goal to bring this concept
into veterinary medicine with the help
of two great veterinary physician
scientists at Penn that we set to test
the idea of precision medicine in the
cancer that Jakob and so many other dogs
suffered from hemangiomas our coma
Nahum angiosarcoma short for HSA is that
aggressive malignant sarcoma one of the
most common cancers in dogs in almost
100% fatal most dogs die within six
months of diagnosis due to metastatic
spread to the lung and it is
over-represented in German Shepherd
golden retrievers and Labrador
retrievers these features make HSN an
excellent disease to pioneer precision
medicine such that there is a readily
available tissue desperate clinical need
and a potential human clinical correlate
with human angiosarcoma as they are very
similar is to pathologically but human
angiosarcoma is just too rare to study
hypothesize that if we assess tumour
mutation profiles
via next-generation sequencing we will
identify uncle Janek drivers and a
clinical actionable targets which will
hopefully advance therapy and improve
outcomes for this desperate disease to
address our hypothesis first we
performed whole exome sequencing to
investigate mutation landscape of NIH sa
and identified oncogenic drivers and
biomarkers that have looked tential a
prognostic and therapeutic values next I
built a targeted resequencing panel to
validate these style markers in a larger
cohort also explore the research and the
clinical utility of panel sequencing in
veterinary medicine finally we'll
evaluate these markers in prospective
studies such as clinical trial
our whole exome workflow is fairly
straightforward except that we have to
use tonight exome capture solution
instead of human and we did sequence
those tumor in the match normal tissue
as a control the annotation and
interpretation of the results however is
very challenging since canine cancer
annotation is very limited at this point
or not available at all so we had to
rely heavily on human data to predict
and understand the function of the
mutated genes the pathways involved and
most important of all the implication of
mutations in cancer our customer to
hybrid informatics pipeline
you know enable us to identify potential
drivers and their biological and the
clinical implication
together our exome sequencing identifies
identified candidate driver Jansing more
than half the cases each column here
represent an individual taste taste ID
show amount top each role represent
candidate driver gene ring squares here
show the non nonsynonymous mutations and
a black squares are truncating mutation
out of the four potential driver genes
to love them our uncle genes pik3ca and
the plc gamma 1 & 2 love them our tumor
suppressor genes p53 and p10 several
points I like I like to emphasize here
not only are the genes well-established
cancer genes the mutations we identified
here are also well documented oncogenic
mutations as shown in human cancer such
as pik3ca h 104 7 r which is the most
common activating mutation in TCGA genes
and the p10 loss of function mutations
and the plc gamma 1 activating mutation
so we're very excited about this results
however we can ignore the fact that
exome sequencing was unable to detect
drivers in almost another half cases
based on several lines of evidence
i hypothesized it's because exome
sequencing is just not sensitive enough
due to its limited coverage so we
decided to test a more sensitive
strategy targeted panel resequencing
which focuses on a limited number of
genes that are involved in commando
sarcoma tumor Genesis
if it's designed based on our own exome
sequencing data and of course available
genomic data angiosarcoma in both
species it covers a full coding region
of 24 genes and hotspot mutation in
another sentence a total 31 genes
including these include oncogenic driver
genes recurrent mutated genes and
hotspot mutations that are indicated in
both species and a few also include a
few common cancer genes in human and
canine solid tumors just to wipe the you
widen the utility of this panel for
methods I chose to use the Illumina
amplicon phase the targeted resequencing
solution it's perfect for a panel decide
and also compatible to use with the FFPE
samples if that's what we mostly get
hang on sequencing reproduced exome
sequencing findings by identifying
candidate driver genes in these four
genes and in the original cases as well
but it also makes new discoveries it
identify detected potential driver genes
in another eight tumors as indicated by
the triangles here in this new paces not
only do we see the original cancer for
cancer genes also found new recurrent
undress mutations in three cases the
allele frequency after of the record
areas operations is relatively low which
may explain why we missed it from exome
sequencing data
so the regard recurrent unrest mutation
a sound here is that q61 to our mutation
in human this is a well known activating
mutation of unrest and a driver multiple
cancer types such as the melanoma and
lung cancer unrest is our attractive
therapeutic targets with drugs available
to tart to inhibit it and unrest is that
also stamp the same mutation is also
found in human angiosarcoma
which is evidence that pain item
angiosarcoma have strong human correlate
could could be a good model for human
angiosarcoma unrest Newton was missed by
the discovery sequencing while detected
by panel sequencing highlighting the
sensitivity of targeted panel sequencing
in this case so next we employed the HSV
panel described above to sequence
additional 30 HSA tumors results of all
50 cases are summarized here I observed
the same set of conka-chonk driver genes
the previously described throughout all
samples as you can see unrest is
observed in 12 out of 50 cases and 24 -
MERS their pics receiving mutation the
reason I put P 10 P 3 CA and P 10
together in the same box is because
tienen secret they are both two
components of PS retail pathways and p10
in activating mutation operates in
parallel with PCA activating mutation
both leads to elevated PS reach a
signaling and present a very attractive
therapeutic targets for drug
intervention
cases we sequence so far I didn't find
obvious drivers in four cases and as you
can see six cases has only six cases
have only p53 mutations while no other
major oncogenic drivers this could
reflect the presence of somatic
aberrations not detectable by the
sequencing method we employed such as in
a genomic large-scale rearrangement and
copy number variations or could be due
to poor the inequality in these samples
and able to make satisfying and become
based the sequencing libraries but
overall the panel is informative for 92%
of patients demonstrating high
diagnostic utility
notice that there is no overlapping
between the major driver groups
suggesting that these drivers might
represent distinctive molecular subtypes
of the HSA that were previously thought
as a single entity disease as shown here
by this histology image
several subtypes
several subtypes such as unrest
53 and the PLC gamma1 they are found
identical
we found the even identical mutations
between k Nahum angiosarcoma and human
angiosarcoma suggesting that although
genetically heterogeneous a subset of
tina HSA shared genetic similarities
between human a.s and could serve as a
suitable model on the other hand pik3ca
p10 mutant group and unrest mutant group
represent two great therapeutic targets
football for from collage achill
interventions and they account for more
than 70% of HSA cases there are both
fda-approved drugs and a trial drugs
available to inhibit these targets
the genomic data is the very companion
but the question remains
does the genotype correlate with
phenotype whether upstream mutations
actually lead to deregulated downstream
signaling to that end we did
immunohistochemistry on this on the same
slide on the same cases as you can see
here the IHC staining show beautiful
signal thoughtful earth in unrest mutant
cases but for Earth is a classic marker
of map kinase pathway activation
indicating strong strong association of
unrest mutation with map kinase
signaling also a direct evidence that
unrest Newton is driving commando
sarcoma tumor Genesis
similarly the activation of picture CA
signaling is confirmed by the expression
of phosphate KT and the fossil s6 to
downstream effectors of pi3k an mTOR
pathway
function study is particularly
gratifying since it's consistent with
previous findings that pi3k and a map
kinase pathway pathways are frequently
activated in Cana hemangioma
and now our mutation data provide a
genetic mechanism for this phenotype
at the end of this process we have in
hand a validated functional relevant
cost-effective NGS test which allows us
to rapidly screen archived cases for
research purposes but also have the
potential to screen standard veterinary
patient samples in routine clinical care
this panel allows us to begin to study
aspects of K Nahum angiosarcoma that
were previously unthinkable in the
interest of time I'll show you here how
this panel our genomic findings have
powered the design and the development
of precision clinical trials providing
that one but two options in one scenario
typing using HSE panel presents drugs or
targets based on the data I have so far
50% of HSE cases with ticks receive ppad
mutations are eligible for VIP retain
Jupiter or Emperor inhibitor trial and
25% patients harboring unrest mutants
will be zero can be enrolled in math
inhibitor trial and there are drugs
available as shown here these are all
the fda-approved drugs
and uh but you know finding affordable
drugs is another story luckily our works
isn't an alternative opportunity by
taking advantage of the extremely
construing mutation mutation landscape
of HSA and the design listeria based
material vector based a new antigen
immunotherapy trial this study is
currently underway in carburation with a
vac system and here as the result of the
mutation profiling we were able to
introduce the HSA specific mutation to
the restoral platform and make an app
the shell the vaccine product to treat
HSA dogs that carried these mutations
and hopefully the special life the
vaccine will help train the immune
system to recognize an acute cancer
cells in a very targeted manner in
either scenario it's reasonable to think
that our genomic approach may lead to
novel therapeutic options and transform
how can a hemangioma is treated this is
just one example of the various
advancements our genomic approach and
HSA panel will make and a perfect segue
to move into the last section of my talk
here I want to re-emphasize the
long-term goal of our collaborative
effort is to bring precision medicine to
the practice of veterinary oncology
build on the rich experience gathered in
hemangioma study I have turned my effort
to build a comprehensive canine cancer
panel we enable the same kind of deep
genotyping phenotyping and hopefully a
clinical advancement for all canine
cancers as we did hemangioma together
our broad cancer panel detects a wide
range of mutations in 200 284 genes
no one to drive cancer development it
covers a total target region of the 1/4
megabases in Cana genome and this is
almost 4% of the whole exome remember
these genes are all cancer related
/ method I chose to use the hybrid
capture based enrichment sequencing
solution and this is down by twist
goal is to map mutation landscape
identify drivers biomarkers to arm
researchers and the veterinary
clinicians with better prognostic
information targeted therapeutic options
and biomarkers to predict treatment
response for common cancers in dogs the
design the the broad canine cancer panel
covers genes in key signaling pathways
that no one to play a role in cancer
development such as a PS retain not
settle and the desire of the broader
cancer panel is multifold not only is it
card targeting the cancer pathways it
also covers potential driver genes in
top 10 common tonight cancers such as a
lymphoma osteosarcoma team angiosarcoma
to the best of our knowledge this is by
far the largest and most comprehensive
cancer gene sequencing panel in
veterinary medicine and we are very
excited about it
with every opportunity comes with a
decent amount of challenges here I'm
going to show you a few lessons we've
learned during this process first the
design of the probes most design tools
that are currently available are for a
human
you think it's easy switch between human
genome to cana genome turns out it
actually requires to do some serious
coding changes and the informatics
resources eventually twist had to
basically reviewed the whole design
pipeline for non-human species including
canine and mouse now that they have it
hopefully future designs for non-human
species will be very straightforward
just a heads up or for those of you who
are doing non-human genomic
second it's a common practice to add
blotting reagent to the hybridization
reactions to reduce now the purpose is
to reduce nonspecific binding associated
with the repetitive sequences sequences
in the genome to improve capture
specificity and accuracy human cut one
DNA is such a blocking reagent it is
enriched for repetitive non-coding
elements commonly found in a human
genomic DNA
at first we were we just assumed that we
can use human cut one in our tonight
hybridization reactions assuming that it
will do the same with canine samples but
our target rate really suffered before I
did some digging and I realized that
there is actually not sufficient
sequencing homology between human and
canine genome for that to work the
moving forward can a specific blockers
are the way to go this is a lesson for
us and hopefully for other researchers
as well
currently the design and the synthesis
is all down and a validation is underway
the maxixe looks actually really good
based on you know initial testings with
high uniformity and the low duplication
rate and we're just working out a few
kinks to improve on target I'm using
hemangioma cohort as validation sample
sets of course because they're mutation
contents are well studied now at this
point I'm glad to find out that the new
panel confirms previous results you know
all the variants that I found that are
supposed to be there are picked up by
the new panel such as P P 3 P 10 P 3 CA
and now we also make new detections such
as for what like the potential drivers
in samples that I didn't find anything
before or I found p53 mutation only so
in a why's that
I think combining with the APRI
analytical factors for these samples
which mostly have really poor DNA
quality to begin with we think it's
likely reflected in like it
it likely reflect the fact that
hybridization approach is more tolerable
for poor DNA quality than the amplicon
approach
by far between the discovery sequencing
the small focus panel and the broad
panel
I have almost 100% diagnostic utility 14
item angiosarcoma and this is the model
I'd like to introduce to other tonight
cancers and hopefully other species as
well
so in conclusion of our effort in
bringing precision medicine to clean
item angiosarcoma our genomic approach
allowed us to identify driver mutations
in most HSA cases tested which leads to
better understanding of the biology and
the pathogenesis of cain item
angiosarcoma as well as human
angiosarcoma we demonstrate that coneja
Menjou sarcoma is consists of multiple
molecular subtypes some subgroups bear
similar driver mutations with human AAS
suggesting strong human correlate then
the drug above molecular subtypes on the
other hand help to guide precision
clinical trial design and a rapid
evaluation of novel therapy strategy and
eventually tailored effective treatment
our HSA project serves as a
proof-of-concept study to enable
precision medicine in other tonight
cancers it already led to the
development of the comprehensive cancer
panel for tonight our work here is not
only valuable for veterinary patients we
may also be able to translate any
results for similar human diseases
particularly in a case of rare diseases
that are difficult to study to mount a
meaningful clinical trial
not to mention finding a targeted
therapy in the end this is a really a
win-win situation for both people and
our companion animals so this is my with
that so this is my funding sources and
these are the people that are closely
involved involved in in this effort and
special thanks to dr. David Ross Nicola
Mason and Amy doom but you know everyone
can do this
without them and with that I'd like to
close today's talk and write by saying
that I'm currently seeking actively
seeking collaborations and the tumor
samples feel free to reach out if you
are interested in certain canine cancers
I'll have access to tumor samples thank
you so much
precision medicine virtual event my name
is Dwayne Hasani I'm an assistant
professor of computational biomedicine
and medicine at Weill Cornell Medicine
and director of leukaemia genomics for
the englander Institute for precision
medicine today I'm going to talk to you
about total hematopoiesis and pre
leukaemia please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation and
I'll follow up with you by email
so a little bit of a quick background my
lab works in the area of acute myeloid
leukemia it's a fatal disease with
dismal outcomes the most pertinent fact
for this presentation is the fact that
it's a sudden onset disease so people
typically present suddenly and there
sometimes individuals who progressed
from MDS AML but many people it's a very
devastating and sudden diagnosis so they
come in typically other physicians will
refer to something as a Friday night
leukemia typically it happens before
weekends we get our samples on the
weekend and it's because you know people
feel that they are under the weather and
are seeking medical attention at the ER
you know to solidify their weekend plans
but what happens is what they thought
may have been a cold or flu in time
turns into a leukemia diagnosis and
unlike many cancers it has to be
addressed immediately so there's really
an unmet need for identification of
high-risk individuals who need to be
monitored for risk of AML so can we
identify in the population of healthy
individuals those who are more likely to
progress there now the disease it's
actually relatively rare occurring you
know in a handful 400,000 people so
depending on the age category that we
can consider to occur five to a hundred
thousand people
and now like many cancers arises via the
stepwise acquisition of mutations so it
is a disease of the hematopoietic system
and it begins you know with this
pristine hematopoietic system that we're
essentially born with that acquires
somatic mutations over time somatic
mutations are generally not selected for
so most somatic mutations are neutral so
we're pretty much developing these
mutations even before birth so they're
they're accumulating but really with no
selection pressure but over time there's
this that this process of expansion that
occurs via selective pressures or just
random mutations that gain a clonal
advantage so this clonal expansion is
termed clonal inadequacies it's actually
quite common in the general population
so if you look at it at a population of
individuals that are about 50 years of
age or older
we find in other studies find that more
recent studies find the 25 percent of
individuals over 50 years of age exhibit
some form of mutation in their blood
typically these mutations occur in very
specific genes which I'll get to
but these genes also happen to be the
genes that are supposed risk for acute
myeloid leukemia so with the early
driver that's keep myeloid leukemia but
most people the vast majority people are
fine and don't get me Kingdom so we're
interested in actually understanding or
what it is that discerns a leukemia gene
that's likely a mutation that's likely
to progress to leukemia versus a
mutation that's not likely to progress
to leukemia these mutations accumulate
you develop leukemia stem cells and then
further mutational complexity we develop
a full-blown leukemia
koala Mattapoisett occurs in genes that
are associated with AML so we can see
here and this is there several reports
this is a more recent report from Nature
communications looking at the mutation
spectrum of people's healthy blood so we
can see most mutations occur in gay men
to create to be course tag to ASX l 1k
rasa seen in some cases these are the
mutations that are important for the
early events in AML they're just found
and a very significant number of people
so they're they're healthy persons so
what we need to do is discern what it is
that differentially differentiates these
mutations from mutations that progress
to leukemia so the there were studies
going back to 2014 and a little bit
before that as well but there were two
major papers that came out in 2014 in
the New England Journal of Medicine one
was by Josh wall and colleagues the
other one was by Jenna BC and colleagues
and what they did was they had looked at
large population cohorts and looked at
the risk of progression to any
hematologic malignancy not just AML and
found essentially that even though the
risk is obviously not absolute for
progression tending hematologic
malignancy disposed at 11 to 13 fold
risk of eventual analogic malignancy so
this is not just a now it's AML with
other myeloid neoplasms certain
lymphomas and CLL all of that included
certain high risk presentations of
clonal hematopoiesis confer a 1% rate of
progression to him at a logic malignancy
per year so this is a risk that
accumulates over time in that high risk
presentation it it actually roughly
approximates the progression from Angus
to myeloma which is another precursor
condition so quantumatic oasis is a
condition that could be thought of as a
precursor condition in very particular
context in addition glottal
hematopoiesis confers an elevated risk
of cardiovascular disease so for those
individuals who are not progressing to
cancer depending on a specific mutation
pattern
in specific and the specific
cardiovascular event you're looking at a
two-fold risk that some some lists for
tenfold more by in terms of
cardiovascular disease so these clones
are not a nerd even in the people who
are not progressing to having to logic
cancers turns out and there's a body of
literature demonstrating a wide variety
of pro-inflammatory and prolonged
inflammatory responses of these
individuals favoring things like the
accumulation of macrophages in arterial
wall so this is a general and huge
health concern that needs to be studied
more carefully to determine what the
risk factors are for particular
individuals
we've seen the clonal hematopoiesis
Aseem concurrent with AML this is
intuitively obvious so if you look at
the slide I showed previously regarding
the progression from normalcy to acute
myeloid leukemia there's a stepwise
acquisition of mutations and sometimes
the precursors are still dominant clones
so early and this is a actually a filmer
poster we presented back in 2012 what we
did was we were looking to see what the
mutation patterns were in achieve
myeloid leukemia patients to identify
you know whether there were differences
in the compartments of an individual's
disease so we could see is if you look
at dnmt3a which is one of the canonical
from hematopoiesis mutations the most
common one dnmt3a mutations were present
in the bulk stem and lymphocyte
compartment so indicating that these
were early events occurring in a stem
cell they were mutations were propagated
into the lymphoid and into the myeloid
compartment if we look at n wrasse here
n rosters another mutation presence in
that individuals AML unlike dnmt3a
it was not present in the lymphocytes
looking at the panel on the right so we
can see that in the bulk AML on the AML
stem cell fraction which is
phenotypically defined and sorted we can
see that the mutation is occurring in
the myeloid malignancy but the lymphoid
compartment is completely pristine in
this regard so what we think is
happening on this model which is
consistent with what I showed previously
is that dnmt3a mutation acquisition is
an early event it is propagated into the
lymphoid compartment and then some
fraction of lymphocytes will demonstrate
dnmt3a mutations but once there's
myeloid commitment and wrasse mutations
are acquired and this leads to overt
disease suggesting the utility of an
early detection strategy if we could
actually determine what individuals with
particular mutations will progress to
AML so our lab became very interested in
predicting AML as I said before it is an
emergency condition and more than half
of presentations of AML are sudden with
no prior warning
no precursor condition no MDS no other
hematologic abnormality so we sought to
determine if we could define a pre
leukemic state that is different from
chrono hematopoiesis or identify at
least what the various risks are the
particular mutation patterns in
individuals with regard to that risk so
we looked at the impact of specific
coronal mutations that were present in
any key malignancy no study to date has
evaluated serial samples at the point
that we initiated the study to look at
the chrono kinetics so the UM the how
these mutations inform the timing from
detection to present excuse me the
presentation of disease and our goal
really was to there's an acronym used in
the field clonal hematopoiesis of
indeterminate potential which is meant
to underscore the uncertain nature of
what will happen with individuals with
chromatic releases and so we wanted to
move more and more away from
indeterminate
so to do this we could have done it
prospectively would have taken many many
years but what we had access to was the
Women's Health Initiative study so we
turn to blood samples that were banked
going back to the early 90s 1991 and
were followed for up to 20 years so all
of what I'm showing you is actually
published in our Nature Medicine study
which is shown here it's the published
main article and their various
interesting perspectives articles those
are accompanying news and views from Rob
sellers adjustable and Bini Burt in the
same dish in the same issue and various
highlights articles that get various
different perspectives on what our data
actually mean so I actually encourage
anyone to read those our study design
drew from the Women's Health Initiative
cohort which comprised 160 1808 women
who are fifty to seventy nine years of
age at baseline valuation and these
women are 50 years older and all
postmenopausal so that's one aspect of
one manner in which our population
differs somewhat from a general
population in the 50 to 79 year old
group it's all women all postmenopausal
from this we're able to identify 212
centrally adjudicated cases of AML these
are individuals with a confirmed a no
diagnosis during whi follow-up and 9.6
years was the medium time to diagnosis
in 188 cases that we could evaluate by
next-generation sequencing alongside
that we have age matched obviously
gender matched controls they were
matched by age non AML cancer history
and 181 of those were valuable by NGS
from those we actually have the largest
serial sequencing study of Crow
hematopoiesis with 132 individuals who
follow up at one year three years or 128
serial samples at one year for three
years and to do this we perform deep
targeted sequencing using a targeted
panel at a 2,000 X median depth of
coverage which we were calling events
down to 1% variant allele fractions
there's some controversy in the
literature's to what comprises a right
clone size and I think what the field is
looking for are more data-driven more
clinically driven approaches to defining
what those cut-offs should be in
addition to that because we used a large
in solution capture panel we were able
to identify translocations so it
actually included intronic dates as well
as well copy number events so we've got
this very broad molecular portrait of
genes that are involved in both lymphoid
and myeloid malignancies to look at what
the mutation state is like in healthy
individuals at an average of nine point
six years at a median of nine point six
years prior to their diagnosis so it's
very important to remember is that these
are healthy women at baseline so if you
look at the AML cases so they in all
cases are individuals who've developed
it now and you look at any dependent
parameters you look at hematocrit white
blood count hemoglobin platelets there's
really no difference between the control
in the case group so this is the case
control design and these parameters are
largely similar between the two groups
so no no real differences here so these
are people who are generally
hematological II normal who wouldn't
really trigger any red flags in terms of
eddiemetal logic parameter yet they're
harboring in some cases mutations so we
did is we took this cohort and we deeply
sequenced it using our first panel and
this is essentially what the mutation
spectrum looks like so on the left side
you can see the AML cases with the red
title that's 188 individuals and 181
matched controls so you can see right
away that the a.m. of the people who
developed a male so these are pre AML
cases have more mutations in a more
complex mutation spectrum so not only do
you see singleton mutations that you see
more kool mutations and just generally a
higher proportion of individuals were
mutated notably absent though are
flicked vit D and PM one so to an
individual who's a trained trained
leukemia expert
looking at this it looks very much very
similar to the mutation spectrum you
would see if we looked at one of the
classical AML papers looking early on
some work by Tim ley going back several
years now if you look at the controls
you see the controls are mostly pristine
so we have dnmt3a mutations in the
significant number the cohort some
tattoo mutations but really hardly
anything else much much simpler mutation
pattern many fewer individuals rotated
we also were able to detect some copy
number changes so we saw in a Galician
13 solution 7q and some trisomies in a
few individuals
the pre AML to reiterate is more complex
so if you actually looked at the same
individual if not were only were they
mutated some of them had multiple
mutations per gene this is a feature
that was not as commonly in the Pennine
quo on that alesis group who did not
develop animal so if you look here for
example at tattoo which is a nice and
interesting example uh tattoo cases
present in most cases in many cases and
more probably half of cases here are
showing more than one mutation so
individuals who have more than one key
mutation are indicated by the non red
color shown there so some have two
mutations some pesky mutations that's
indicated in the number of variants key
down below so there are definitely
people who have more two mutations per
individual this is a finding that was
not seen in any individual in the
creative alcove in the in the control
cohort which is actually an interesting
finding because in AML when it's
diagnosed de novo individuals present
typically the single tattoo mutation so
you know theoretically with this opposes
the possibility for is a some driver
process that's favouring multiple tattoo
mutations and one of those tattoo
mutations goes on to progress to AML and
the other tattoo mutation doesn't
progress so I think we would actually
deeply sequence AML individuals at
tattoo new patients we might find a non
dominant subclone that is only tattoo
mutated this is something that needs to
be tested
but we thought that that was an
interesting way of discerning the cases
from the controls
more importantly we had a 30% rate of
clonal hematopoiesis previous studies
we're talking about rates in the five to
ten percent range so we did a lot of
things differently than than we've done
previously and this is basically due to
technical limitations of the previous
studies they had exams sequencing data
they use the eggs or sequencing data
they had to do a great study that these
were done on ad
and there were some issues with agile
whole eggs on sequencing especially
around Ted too so I'm doing this showing
you an IG v image the top track is
showing a representative example of a
Agilent wrist Alecto leg zone 2 and what
we're showing here is the relatively
poor coverage that was and this is
actually acknowledged in the paper so if
you actually read the Supplemental data
in the jaws wall jeanna BC study this
this fact is alluded to in in each of
the studies but if you look at the panel
we developed we're sequencing much much
deeper and we're actually covering all
the eggs on so about half of the egg
zones are actually being missed in
tattoo and that's actually quite a
substantial amount of eggs on space so
just from you know from eggs on coverage
alone we expected our tattoo mutation
rate to be double and then from depth of
coverage we expect it to be higher than
that so we think that our rate of tattoo
mutations is accurate and that most
studies previously through no fault of
their own were just underpowered just
due to the available data that they had
so going back again the just well Jenna
VC studies in 2014 sequenced at 70 to 80
X there's a more recent paper that
sequence at about 500 X there's a Coon's
at all Cell Stem Cell paper looking at
chromatic releases and solid tumors
using the NS k impact panel but we can
see from study Nature communications by
shining' colleagues where they were
looking at how powered you need to be to
detect mutations at certain variant
allele fraction cut-offs to detect a 2%
variant allele fraction cutoff which is
a working definition for Kalamata
polices we need at least a thousand x
coverage so you can see here at below
100x they're really poorly poorly power
to detect anything you know below you
know 10 10% in this case so you're
hugely underpowered you're missing
missing four out of five events
occurring the low path range so it's a
huge underestimation but nonetheless the
the conclusions
of the the old studies are accurate and
our conclusions seem to be accurate and
consistent so this is just showing the
various technical definitions of chroma
hematopoiesis and depending on the
allelic fraction cut-offs that are used
and the standardization approach and
what is called pathogenic you can see it
can vary so we can't actually make it in
line with previous studies if we use
parameters that were used by previous
studies showing our studies actually
relatively consistent with with the
previous work overall we had generally
great coverage across the board so we're
showing on the major mutations
associated with chromatic voices in
leukemia dnmt3a tattoo p53 ASX l1 SRS
ft/s F 3 B 1 a DHT jack 2 great coverage
and all the genes very few low spots
interesting mutation patterns who
noticed was that younger patients had a
young biller there's a younger age of
onset for mutations in DNA mt-32 for the
pre ml cases versus controls so if you
look at tattoo for example if you look
in the under 65 group 10% were mutated
in to it under the age of 65 an
individual Sugata ml but barely any
12.6% so essentially a five-fold
increase in the mutation rate of
individuals about a ml when these
mutations were detected in the under 65
group so individuals progressing to a
male demonstrated mutations at an
earlier age than individuals do not
progress stable the risk is actually
elevated by the particular mutation and
the number of mutations so the most
risky mutation we found this p53
followed by a double positive tattoo so
actually the double positive tattoo
mutations rival the risk that was
present with p53 so both demonstrating
more than 50 fold odds ratio single Tet
T mutations were risky same pattern with
DN into a BB and mp3 a we could see the
risk goes from two to twelve point six
if two or more
dnmt3a mutations mutations in one
crucial AML driver gene ID h1 or h2
demonstrated a 30-fold risk we saw some
some increase with Jack to an increase
of spliceosomes or splices on being sf3
b1 mutations SRS f2 and zr s r2 we
didn't see a pattern with ASX l1 so it's
important when you come away from this
slide to not think that if you detect
p53 in an individual and a healthy
population that that means that they're
going to get ano so in our study no
individuals who in the healthy group had
a p53 or an idh mutation but there's
really two important caveats to note
there you walk away from this one is a
p53 is a precursor to other conditions
CLL for example and
our study with a case control design so
what we did this we have this assert
Ament bias in which we selectively
individuals who developed AML the stuck
we were to proceed into a CLL study we
would also expect the p53 being a CLL
driving mutation would also demonstrate
a risk not sure what the magnitude would
be but the general principle will be the
same in the future between it shows a
higher risk theoretically we haven't
going to experiment in and our sample
size so we're looking at 181 cases it's
possible that if we sequence thousands
of cases we might try and p53 in ith
mutations that did not progressed and
out but nonetheless the odds are
significantly increase so high risk
mutation patterns here seem to be p53
mutations ith mutations and TT mutations
the people with mutations if you imagine
AML progressing from the stepwise
acquisition of mutations the more steps
you've taken the closer you are to
getting in L that's exactly what we see
with the data so here we're looking at
key mode of analyses looking at
individuals with no mutation versus
individuals or having mutation if you
look at the panel on the left you can
see these two curves and anybody that
any mutation developed and all at a
sooner time than individuals who had no
mutations and we developed AML so
looking at 12 years and median time to
diagnosis and individuals who presented
no mutation that's accelerated to a
number closer to seven and individuals
who had any mutation whatsoever in their
blood if you look at the stepwise
acquisition of mutations the expectation
is the more mutations you have the
faster you progressed AML and that's
exactly what you see the individuals no
mutation are still taking about twelve
years to develop one mutation takes just
a little bit under ten years but we're
moving closer now the six years with
individuals were tuning more mutations
so you can see that progressive shift
downward as individuals acquire more
mutations
we also find that greater clonal
complexity and clone size are related
and consistent again with the intuition
I was just presenting about oncogenesis
the individuals who have large clothes
that have become dominant with allelic
fractions of over 10% demonstrates an
increased risk relative to individuals
who have lower than 10% allelic
fractions the same holds true and even
more true for tattoos so high-risk
tattoo over ten percent lower risk below
10% splicing zone showed a trend toward
this but the trend was not wildly
significant but you can still see that
there's a difference if you also look at
the maximum clone size so that would be
the largest clone so if you have a clone
of 25% allelic fraction just
hypothetically what we found is that the
larger the clone size the more
commutation compared so if you look at
the ml cases you can see as the clone
size increases on the y-axis the number
of cool mutations increases and controls
this held true as well but not to the
same extent and nobody had five
mutations on the controls so you can see
again the the mark short AML is very
evident more so even if you look at the
right pen
so we also as I said before did probably
the largest serial sequencing study of
automatically so so we're able to look
at individuals I have one year three
years here I'm showing you three year
and the plots showing a real attraction
at baseline on the x-axis and we'll
attraction at year three I pick on the
y-axis is you can see dnmt3a mutations
largely sit on the diagonal meaning no
change tattoo mutations not very many or
change most are still sitting on the
diagonal p53 mutations there's a bit of
an increase is much more of an increase
of SRS at to an IV h2 if you look at the
mutation specific risk using a
statistical model accounted for Co
mutations and looking at the independent
risk of these pose what we can see is
that idh mutations generally show the
greater clonal growth of per unit time
independently of SRS f2u to AF one so
these are all individual risks for these
mutations which is consistent with the
plot shown on the left
different patterns of coevolution
between baseline and diagnosis so as
individuals progressed 2ml the
subsequent clones got bigger and
acquired more mutations I'm showing you
four cases here these are explained in
the manuscript in more detail if you
look at them but I think for the
purposes of this discussion we can look
at case a so case a is a as a woman who
presented a baseline with only an ith
canonical mutation in the r-1 community
it goes in our 1:32 and this mutation is
present at just over 5% allelic fraction
at baseline as I said before driver
events for that they promote the
progression to leukemia so quickly.i TDM
MP and one or hugely common events in
AML those weren't present in the healthy
group but we can see here is that she
went in for her baseline evaluation for
follow-up to her baseline evaluation at
one year when we look at that at one
year we can see that an NPM one mutation
popped up but this person was actually
still considered healthy for whatever
reason but it turned out 27 days later
after that what year one time point the
person developed an AML diagnosis so
this shows you that the early events
leading to AML which is this case the
ith two mutation are present but the
progression to ml required the
introduction of a cooperating mutation
in npm one and once that mutation
appeared at some point between zero and
one year the progression to ml was very
quick also again in under a month after
this diagnosis
all I think our study defined a number
of high risk factors for AML but we're
still not in a position where we could
look at it an individual in the
population and say you are an absolute
risk we even have a 95% probability they
know we're really far from that but we
can do is identify mutations that are
mutations that are higher risk and what
to do about those mutations is an open
question but what we do know is that the
highest risk is mutations in p53 idh1
and ith - our cohort anybody who had
those mutations developed AML it doesn't
mean that in a larger population so if
we sample 10,000 people suppose 181 we
might find a false positive rate large
clones greater than 10% allelic fraction
demonstrated a significantly increased
risk we found multiple type 2 mutations
posed a risk that was very comparable to
a piece of d3 mutation and we think
that's interesting something to pay more
attention to why seizo mutations
co-occurring especially a dnmt3a were
risky anybody with one or more mutation
had risk and anybody with a fast-growing
clone for p53 or ith - so if the p53 a
right each mutation were static over a
period of three years not changed those
individuals were much lower risk than
individuals who um showed an increase in
clone size and this is this is outlined
well and the actual paper so we need to
do better obviously because like I said
before we don't have the ability to to
look at these to look at just mutations
and say you're at an individual that's
going to proceed pea now I think it's
probably worth watching idh1 in ith to
individuals but in other cases it's not
entirely clear so we're working at our
Center to really include many more
parameters so we want medical data so
identifying Atlas persons based on
health abnormalities so we're blowing
machine learning approaches to see
if your high normal white blood count
versus a low normal white blood count
plus a mutation how does that actually
modify your risk so incorporating data
outside of the mutation spectrum looking
at epigenetic genetic marks so do you
have a genetic marks provide added
information on people guesses pay of now
or not there's an interesting study
showing a higher rate of nomadic Elisa's
mutation it's not pea radiated some bio
archive demonstrating an epigenetic age
is associated with the presence of
global map voices these mutations are
epigenetic modifiers genes so it's an
actual it's an interesting entanglement
between the two processes then serum
factors so full on that alesis has been
associated with the increase in
inflammatory factors
so there's population data actually
showing this so you know do immunologic
allanne metabolic parameters even help
distinguish cree and all from you know
so it's definitely important to get
other parameters into this equation
medical history epigenetic data and
further improving the risk
stratification because again this is a
very rare disease of the disease
occurring in you know few and hundred
thousand people so a false positive rate
of 1% is actually very high in a rare
disease that's occurring and you know
like I said five and 100,000 people we
have a huge false positive rate so this
is something needs to be refined in
terms of why we would do at a population
level we think as the risks of the
climatic release exposes in
cardiovascular disease becomes more and
more established the probability of it
becoming incorporated in a standard of
care workup released a subset of
individuals might enable more population
level sequencing so in summary we should
be thinking about the expose ohm so we
should be incorporating baseline
genetics
childhood illnesses history of pathogen
exposure which has been shown to
influence the growth of blood cells
harboring clonal Matthews's mutations
and other such factors given it our
quote on that basis
is a measure of molecular aging explains
us to our molecular aging initiative
that we're conducting in Ishi ating at
the Englander Institute so after all of
this will be decided with it what we
needed was a cheaper test that we've
actually turned precise one we're
looking at genes that are associated
with chromatic releases genes associated
with leukemia and hereditary risk
determinant so things that are known to
influence chromatic releases DNA damage
etc in sequence at high depth over 500
KB capture space that was enabled by
twist technology so we're looking at a
sensitivity target of 1 to 2 percent
variant allele fraction and in doing
that what we're trying to do is we're
trying to make ensure that we are
powered you know at about 95 percent for
mutations occurring at 2 percent or
greater which seem to be clinically
significant this is a moving target
again so as they're more data in the
field establishing what parameters are
important for what cut-offs are
clinically significant we expect this to
be a moving target our data and data
from a few other groups show that a
little fractions of 1% as shown when our
ith two mutations for example and our
study could be clinically significant as
well so but as our as our because our
baseline we're trying to get at least 2%
and we've been sequencing in many cases
to 2,000 X to get that 1% number so off
the bat now Twitter we developed the
platform with twist and got excellent
coverage over the exons that are coding
for dnmt3a so this is again showing the
igv deal and we can see here that
there's excellent depth of coverage and
most exons are covered relatively
uniformly we look at tattoo and we can
compare this going back to the previous
slide I showed you your tattoo most
building exons are well covered for
tattoo there's some variation between
exams but on the high point of this is I
think a few thousand x from the low
point of this is 5
so in terms of what exams are covered so
we have very good coverage for for
tattoo on this particular panel and
precise one and a s XL one did a great
job as well so the last two we actually
with an approach as there are new
resistance determinants and interesting
variants being identified all the time
we actually just did all the coding
exons in our precise one panel twist but
the but the last two exons of especially
the last examine a aspects of one of
those that are most important and you
can see great coverage across the coding
region so one thing we were particularly
happy with was coverage GC which regions
so a particularly challenging gene in an
important gene in AML diagnosis is CB P
alpha so it's actually important for
risk stratification of AML and has some
applications and minimal residual
disease were able to get nice uniform
coverage relatively speaking um across
the entirety of the gene body so in the
middle of CB p alpha there's a very GC
they extract because you can't see in
this particular plot but the very middle
tends to be very poorly covered in many
first runs so we actually had a
relatively decent outcome in pimping
when our first interaction with twist on
this is also very though we find that
the GC of each region there's a little
bit sensitive to lab techniques so we'll
see a little bit sometimes better than
this sometimes worse than this but never
a complete bald spot in the middle of
CBP officer this is actually a great
result it's also very clean so you can
see here at 1180 x coverage we have no
mutations down to 2% of the reflection
so essentially even could take library
prep protocols and that we're able to
use in the nature medicine study make a
few minor adaptations to facilitate the
twist protocol to do this and
essentially ready to
use the previous library capture go to
library prep protocol with the twist
capture protocol and get a good panel
working off the bat another area where
we were pleased was the excellent
uniformity they got with our precise one
panel so here's a random selection of
ten samples on the y-axis I'm showing
you
millions of pass filter reads and the
full database penalty is shown on the
x-axis and you can see here for the ten
samples all of them had a 1.3 full
database penalty which is I think really
great and this was full database
penalties the sequencing required for
80% of bases to achieve the coverage
median so that was great going forward
we're planning to deploy the precise one
platform at our center to look at larger
cohorts assessing phone automatically
sirs need to perform more detailed QC
analyses of our current platform
applying additional boosting of baits if
needed and we have also able to adapt
and extend the panel to disease specific
applications so if we want it to be a
lymphoma panel you look better than it
is a kinya panel we can easily make
those adaptations and importantly even
you use some of the libraries that we've
already generated so this is a huge
study actually there was made possible
really by by a large team they need to
acknowledge the first authors and lead
authors Pinkel Desai and Maria Mencia
train chimes tinkle uh you know dr.
Desai interacted with the women's health
initiative cohort Maria did much of the
analysis and sequencing support from a
huge huge team we have funding was
provided actually live the chemo
fighters which were thankful some
slideshare were funded by Leukemia
Lymphoma Society
including funding we got from our own
Cancer Center of course we're eternally
grateful to the Women's Health
Initiative for actually making this
study impossible I would have taken many
many years to get to the point
that he did
going to close with my contact
information and the disclosure that this
this talk is sponsored by twist if
anybody has any questions obviously
afraid to contact me using the the
interface or you can email me directly
and I'm also on Twitter happy to discuss
any of the details of the study or any
technical parameters about precise one
test or any other question they have
thank you for listening